these are all it's all common sense
really if you look at a Bible or
whatever a heat-of-the-moment though
yeah everything is just everything is
just okay be selfless like love is
unconditional like do all these things
but what does that really [ __ ] mean
what does it really really mean to put
others first yeah and I mentioned this
on Barton Geo's podcast like one of the
things that I've learned to practice and
I learned a lot of this stuff from my
parents and some other people too this
isn't just some kind of Epiphany I had
on my own it's you know what does it
really mean to give somebody love that
you're with and this is the hard part
for people a lot of the times people
treat their significant other as a pet
and what I mean by that is when my
partner does something good that I like
I give them a treat I say good boy good
girl good yeah good girl that's the easy
thing but what that develops is
something into something actually really
negative because you're thinking that if
this person only does what I say that
they should do then I should praise them
and that becomes a problem because the
the hardest part and the best part that
people should practice is giving person
love when they need it the most
and that is difficult because it's hard
to do that being a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
but there's a reason why they're doing
that and there's a reason why you need
to actually go out of your way to to
uplift them during this really hard time
I'm not saying it's easy because it's
hard for me to and Muriel had to do that
for me the other day because I was
freaking out about stupid [ __ ] I was
being [ __ ] angry I was just Oh long
story short things weren't going my way
that day things were just failing one
after the other yeah I was just in the
house cursing up a storm and then Muriel
all she did was lay next to me and then
she just you know gave me kisses on the
cheek I started like petting my head
like a dog bad example but and it got me
calmed down so instead of turning on you
and being mad at you for being mad
exactly
it's I think it all boils down to our
upbringing mm-hmm like I had this
long-ass conversation with my mom about
my upbringing and I don't remember a lot
of stuff because I was a child but she
was in tears man she was like in tears
one day just like she made this
realization of how badly she's damaged
me and my brother
in conditional love you know cuz mmm
she she's never got unconditional love
mmm only by her dad not by her my my
grandma and my dad in her dad which was
my gambling alcoholic grandpa okay
she loved him to death yeah she said
he's always accepted her always like
supported her whatever and then he
passed so like she lost her
unconditional loving man my father was
conditional love my grandma was
conditional love so my mom really was
surrounded by that conditional love
world and so you know I think this
happens to a lot of Asian kids are just
traditional kids like when you grow up
if you don't perform a certain way your
parents want you to perform you're
almost like hated hmm so it's like oh I
want you to be this doctor or musician
or I want you to have perfect grades or
like if you don't perform those things
you feel be ejected by your parents and
by your family right so what this does
is it creates you to think that you you
know like someone that you love is a pet
yeah they do something good you give
them a treat they do something bad you
hate them for it right so this concept
of loving someone whether they're up or
down or whatever to me it's very foreign
I get angry when people are not
performing well mmm you know what I mean
like in it shouldn't because that that
actually makes them perform even worse
you know Rea like so like like let's say
like I'm a coach right and my my
athletes doing bad if I scold him and
kick him in his ass like he's gonna do
worse cuz it destroys their confidence
but that's all I know and I didn't
realize I was doing the exact same thing
that I hated so much about my parents to
Jess no and it automatically happens
even my thoughts I got a I got a rework
my thoughts it's not that I don't love
her I just don't know how to embody that
because it's not this is learned
behavior it's not natural unconditional
love is an is a learned behavior
it's not natural to the human soul you
know you know I mean like people might
disagree or whatever but it's almost
like if if gambling is normal to in your
family you're probably much gonna be a
gambler when you grow up right same with
if your parents are compulsively lying
all the time you're gonna be able to do
that too right and that's what I mean by
like this expression of love
unconditionally whether someone is up or
down and showing and verbalizing and in
doing all that stuff like that is
something that you have to grow up with
or learn and it takes a long [ __ ]
time yeah long time when I met justice
dad I was observing their relationship
and I was like [ __ ] dude like no matter
what um
he's so [ __ ] warm and accepting and
you don't ever feel like this authority
figure it feels more like a friend yeah
well it's it's weird because he's very
nurturing
he's a nurturing man but he's a man like
he's a man's man like he's a [ __ ]
cook like he's like works with his hands
like he's just somehow he figured out to
play both mom and dad yes oh yeah too
you know yeah and he knows you know like
he knows how to speak in a way where
like he's teaching you wisdom but not
lecturing you and he knows how to tell
stories where like you're you know
you're learning but you don't feel
attacked this is so foreign to me yeah
because you know like growing up Asian
parenting especially aggressive Asian
parents right we're maybe us is a little
bit different but but like the way our
parents talk to us is as if we're not
even human anymore we're [ __ ]
low-lives were stupid we don't know
jack-shit it's almost as if they hate us
you know and then that's if that's what
all you know that's how you start
talking to people you love know like I'm
pretty sure you got it from Mariel to
likely she would if you piss her off
it's almost like she doesn't like you
guys aren't in love anymore
you're outside you this this and this
you're such a dumbass or whatever
so you start lecturing each other it
creates this separation and resentment
and hurt and it's like fog dude like
it's hard cuz it takes you to a place
that you don't want to be in and it's a
place where you look at your partner and
you say I want to hurt you because it's
gonna make me feel better and that's
yeah that's a very bad place to be in
you want to get even
yeah and it's like so bad it's it's it's
scary yeah and my thing was too that I
learned was if you're with somebody and
their happiness doesn't make you happy
and I'm not saying go overboard and
please them and take everything away
from you that's not what I mean I'm
talking about the sense of compromise
where then being happy with you you guys
having a cohesive relationship isn't the
goal then you're probably in a bad
relationship or there's a lot of
learning that needs to go on between
both of you because when you had that
vindictive behavior where revenge is is
what makes you happy like oh well now
this person knows how I feel and they're
hurting so I bet you that they're gonna
do better next time that's already
something bad yeah it never ever works
out well in that case people don't learn
through that way that's why they always
say you catch these better with honey
than vinegar right and it's the same
with people I used to do this with my
brother and I'm a little bit different
in this case I actually had to learn how
to communicate with my older brother a
lot better so how I learned is very
different and Bart knows about this -
I'm the type of person where somebody
tells me I can't do something I go [ __ ]
you i'ma do it you know David you can't
do a cartwheel you're 260 pounds you
were about to see the most funny that's
how he supports he keeps roasting you
all day it's so [ __ ] funny dude it's
like dude I will do the most beautiful
cartwheel you will ever see in your life
you know and that's how I work and I
used to do this thing where my brother
where I thought because my brother I
grew up together obviously I would say I
bet you my brothers are sailing cry yeah
so I would I would [ __ ] berate my
older brother I'm like dude your little
[ __ ] not being a little [ __ ] and
[ __ ] pick yourself up you little
[ __ ] and that it would crush him you
know you know what I found out I'm
actually like that but for things that
are pretty laughable yeah that's like
don't don't you ever talk about my
dreams
considered my sugarcane farm my [ __ ]
mud hut dude that [ __ ] sugarcane
fight that you cut is so funny because
it's such a weird misunderstanding right
so I mean this dude told me this story
where he so Joe is a type of human being
where we're both like this in the sense
of when we find something that we like
we go [ __ ] full force with this yeah
it's a part of our personality yeah but
the problem with him is his hobbies
almost seem like a [ __ ] joke and so
he was like hyper excited talking to
just like you know I'm a dude sugar King
[ __ ] it's gonna be done